you feel like people would still hate
Jar Jar series brought back in an
interesting way no I think people circle
slowly around vision actors you like I
don't like any how perfect
[Music]
hello I'm max landis and bring it down
welcome to the big show I knew this
enhance I as always M here to sit
opposite Jenny Nicholson and fumbling Li
sort of like try to deal with the level
of irony she achieves casually so here
we go we're cutting all of that that
wasn't my intro welcome to the show
everybody
today we're going to be talking about if
max landis was in charge of the Star
Wars universe so prepare for that listen
hey I heard a crazy rumor
it's about Kevin Feige Kevin fart people
were saying like what if they put him in
charge of the Star Wars universe all on
Marvel right you know and then Kathleen
Kennedy would just run like Disney or
she'd be like the Palpatine to his Darth
Vader understand just like control him
like a puppet master
and I was singing because you come up
with like ideas for things sometimes I
was like what if that was you and it was
in charge I don't know what I would do
because I I feel like that's the episode
I feel like the franchising level that
Star Wars is out right now is so tightly
brain controlled has so much riding on
it that that is the antithesis of how I
like to work well can you see it it
already happened as you who are putting
me in charge I'm Kathleen Kennedy hello
I'm Kathleen tell me max what do you
have today honestly I think the most
exciting thing you could possibly do
with Star Wars is use the expanded
universe elements without actually using
much of the expanded universe cannon can
tell individual parceled stories okay
that had deep emotional character depth
you window you in do kotor would stay
away from coat or coat or oh sorry
did you defy your Star Wars did you
search is no nice to the Old Republic
oh yeah well no I know what I took over
right now I could horrible and record
for you wouldn't use that I keep it all
and allow it to be the expanded universe
but I would like to tell individual
stories from the universe so you
wouldn't do a past set Star Wars no I
would do you feel like people would
still hate Jar Jar if she was brought
back in an interesting life no I think
people have circles fully or
found and Star Wars Celebration this
year Hayden Christensen was there and
people are like happy to see him
they were like excited they were like we
forgive you it was so heartwarming it
made me so happy movie I would pitch for
Star Wars okay he's a Jar Jar Binks
mummy okay set in the New Hope era okay
and George ours old mmm-hmm and I would
want it to be like Logan I would want it
that would be great
and I want to be funny human money and
he's still Jar Jar but I would want it
to be like Jar Jar is a guy who's like
down on his luck he's been kicked off of
his planet
he brought Palpatine into power he also
was there he knows who Darth Vader is I
mean why she's a witness to downfall to
Jedi his attitude is miserable and it's
a redemption story about him meaning a
female smuggler okay a kid who found a
lightsaber mm-hmm and she's like this
kids a Jedi I need to get him to safety
because the Empire's haunting him you
use fraud mm-hmm as the villain of the
movie and it's like we've heard there's
a Jedi the trailer could people hate her
so much but if you did like this awesome
Star Wars trailer of like this little
boy with a lightsaber and he doesn't
know how to use the Force if I'm not a
Jedi you have to listen to me so that's
just what she says because she wants to
believe because her father was a Jedi oh
dude well what her father was a Jedi and
she's been trying to like ah doing the
parent saying those 100 yeah okay that
would be a cool individual parcel movie
and the teaser trailer is a who's an
actress you like I don't like any
actresses perfect ah it's a woman who I
have discovered specifically for you
Kathleen oh well offer we did one of the
biggest casting calls in history okay
she is from New Zealand but you can do a
flawless American accent okay
and it's her sitting on a bus Kadena
like real Americans they got to be from
somewhere cooler I'm the teacher is one
shot of this woman in a bar and cigars
you know everybody hates you and it's
just one shot slowly pushing in on her
and she's like everyone knows what you
did I would hate to be you and then flip
to George are at the bar like this and
go where I paddle I don't have reached
out
people on AIA and be absolutely still on
the run so good a really really really
really really great Star Wars movie
could be like Ten Little Indians a group
of disparate people have never met are
all invited to an island and on the
island one of them is a man that hunts
other men no yeah and he goes I'm gonna
hug to my jungle you're thinking of the
most dangerous game which would also be
a good Star Wars movie tell malunions is
really just a really fun book because
it's a great premise and I would love to
do that at like the Jedi Academy where
it's tender someone's been corrupted by
the dark side one of these people who's
come on who they're all kids they're
babies that are dying well I don't want
to young anybody
people love that they are 33 okay pitch
okay be geniuses Star Wars universe same
thing no you don't be good a red herring
for your story that they're all like
three and then one of them's like 17 and
you're like it was that guy but you
don't know yeah but he's in a silly it
was the one weirdly older dude it was
any looking super evil he's got the
clothes it was the youngest kid who
can't even walk yeah he was just for
stroking people from his know he has a
big knife well like she actually
physically relaxed people
he's been stabbing them okay so tell me
more about your Star Wars ideas do you
only have the one I'm working where are
you me Kathleen Kennedy don't dare I'm
sure got me she's like a witch right
sure like a cool which not like you know
not like oh she's a powerful woman
watching today I love you how to which I
just did not on a screen donkey show so
that Kathleen Kennedy was wish I love
the idea of a comedy film that set
inside of the Star Wars universe I think
having to be Han Solo was a stupid idea
it needs to match the tone of the
trilogy enough that it makes sense that
it's still Han Solo yeah but if it was
just other characters you could make it
look like whatever you wanted you know
what would have been a cool way to do
that what do a young Chewbacca movie no
Walker's no I hate it and you know and
the movie is about my kini 10 solo like
near the end I don't care watching Baca
you don't care much for either liner and
I really liked you I like in my like a
scary man is coming through inside as
you know at human eyes
during us yeah if he had big scary
bulbous like tennis ball eyes I mean all
Laurent no I would I would love are you
curious about young Yoda
Oh what are your what's your take on
margin because she's very divisive I
like the idea of her it really bothers
me how they ended her story where she
was just another like source of tragedy
for Luke you think that she's his real
aim and I happened to every girlfriend
in Star Wars like all the time even the
idea of Luke being with a girl is kind
of weak it is a little weird I was
pictured in like a sexless monk that was
like the only good Jedi that could like
stick to the stuff I have no idea what
being a bad person is as defined by the
force I know and like what even being on
the dark side gets you in the dark side
should just be the no rules party how
you're gonna rules party oh yeah I got
your audition we call it that I don't
want to join the dark side you're going
to be like tell like the sound of that
like that sounds evil there's no let-up
at so many 13 year-olds whether you're a
living on like their blog we call
welcome to the dark side dark side and
like play with being on the dark side
that never really do anything to talk
about it yeah
as we Kathleen Kennedy I'm super
concerned because we need crossover
potential like remember this isn't one
movie this is an expanding universe all
a Marvel one of the things that really
confused me was the station of the new
order versus the resist I didn't
understand what the polished political
dynamics were they hate each other right
but they're like is it one terrorist
group fighting another terrorist group
inside of a larger framework of diverse
cultures or is there a republic another
like innocent yeah there is a republic
but the resistance is not part of that
so one of the big crossover things that
I thought would have been really cool is
not to have skipped it you're at least
Jedi Temple Rey is a girl from like a
poor planet doesn't really know who her
parents are but in the opening of the
movie like stands up to sum up to her
bullying bullying her and Luke is like I
think you're a Jedi and she's like I'm
absolutely not you are crazy and he's
like I think your general well why don't
you just come with me and then it's this
incredible movie where you go with
Luke's in the Jedi Temple and she starts
to train to become a Jedi it's and
there's the New Republic and everything
is peaceful and
right think of the see it fall apart and
get to sheer force very movies yeah and
like first organization on the prequels
and I didn't so I never really
understood what was going on in the
force awakens when I watch that movie
excited out of my mind at 2:00 a.m. at
the Grove I like wasn't sure who the
first order was or who was important in
the movie or I got all that you got that
but you took it like a you and I watch
movies similarly and differently mm-hmm
because you were down your criticisms
you've made a force awakens stem from
the fact that you were enjoying it what
waited is not bad hmm it's just it's
it's a willfulness to engage with it and
it was just too fast for me and I never
found my feet and then by the time the
movie ended I was like how did she know
how to do a mind trick how did she pull
the lights over and not to the right a
sense man and make sense man it doesn't
make sense it is the thing that came out
two weeks ago right
I've heard it before whitewater hang
what the thing that there's there was no
plan oh yeah and that every director was
allowed to completely do their own thing
so during the Mary Sue controversy
everyone was yelling at me that it's a
trilogy you have to watch it like a TV
show they know where they're going
and we would read me long things about I
mean that's still decay
except for no it's working backwards
because that during those flashbacks and
stuff they were just spitballing like
Ray definitely but it says something
that her character is incomplete and
that they can do more with her to round
her out more right Ida I didn't have any
issues with their character in this
movie and such as good which was
awakened and for Simon Greene the last
Jedi I'm I'm sorry very curious about
the last Jedi because why should I meet
I think I might go see it in theaters I
don't know might check it out I'm really
I'm gonna play me I think Rian Johnson's
great director but I'm gonna wait
because I went nice all Roselawn and I
thought Rohan disappointed it wasn't a
movie no it was awful it was really I
mean we're not I say this every episode
literally I didn't think it was awful
but yeah but it was the problems I had
with force awakens on a bigger scale
uh-huh
those movies were similar to me and I
know they were so different to everyone
at all but it would also roll warm
do people really service yeah people say
force awakens is just a new hope
rogue one is a war movie for men it's
Star Wars an inherently masculine
property I think that that's kind of
tying into it I don't think it has to be
but I think of the guys who watch it do
you think like yes a man French there's
a man shot ok the the thing about like
having like a spunky cool like female
Jedi from a desert planet whose life
sucks like that sounds awesome and I
feel bad for not liking it you should
you should I like it though yeah but you
should be going bad for liking it no I
feel great I know I could I'm going to
be in the movie theater with my bb-8
stuffed animal and are you excited are
you excited yeah I like I can I'm gonna
wait to like someone know we're really
excited more taste in movies as me goes
like this is a really good no even if
they came out with rogue one too and
they were just like it's the same I
would just I would still go to the night
premiere and be excited wash because
it's fun to be in a midnight premiere
everybody there is like ready for the
movie they're all excited and then
people like cheer and you're like why
are you cheering like well one like clap
I saw look you don't think that's fun to
be in a room with that energy well that
was a great discussion about Star Wars
so now I think it's time for you to
leave leave please okay yeah sure okay
do I get up and go yes you can leave
that one just walk as far as the cable
permits you just kind of shuffle out of
frame and just kind of lost the stoop
over if they don't pull the cable but
just kind of stooped yeah like that's
good that looks so scary like the
babadook or something okay now it's time
to hear the audience's general
grievances about the show
I need to like tell my mic because I'll
laughter you know you won't
I'm not it's not a funny segment ok
legitimate grievances ok ok
I should just be silent yes please
pretend you're not there first comment
is from Abdera mayan they on who said
this show cured my depression that's I'm
so happy for you I wish that would
happen to me but no no maybe if I make
more and more episodes and fill the void
packet full episodes about Star Wars
ok second comment from Steven Abbott who
said step 1 click like step 2 watch the
video so I think that was supposed to be
a compliment but I don't like knowing
that the likes that I have aren't earned
so thanks for nothing Steven please only
like the videos if you legitimately like
them and don't patronize me in such a
way next time okay one more comment is
from Jude Kavanagh it's a long comment
hmm
it says Jenny you're so terrible but
we're better a little bit this week
that's good but can't you do a serious
Star Wars show instead of this nonsense
and by the way I was glad he hit you
with this car on your face thank the
gods and say goodbye properly not like a
three-year-old without a brain God's
damn it
thank you no wait that was a mean
comment don't watch any more episodes or
if you do just click the like button and
don't leave any mean comments then I'll
think I did a good job that's how I earn
all of my likes apparently even okay
that's the episode bye everyone
[Music]
hi
do I look at four year old without a
brain I know you want to meet you